los migrantes hondureños no esperaron el
amanecer para emprender un largo viaje
hacia eeuu con recursos limitados unos
buscan la ayuda de sus compatriotas
mientras que otros hacen pausas para
orar y no sentirse solos la intención de
ir para eeuu es que los otra hemos
perdido todo y aquí lo que queremos lo
que nosotros pedimos como emigrante
desde que el presidente de eeuu que
entró ahorita que por favor los ayude
nosotros aquí no podemos vivir ya
imagínense ahorita
según nosotros vamos a amanecer en la
terminal y tocó que salir nosotras
estamos descansando horita pero no es
como que saliera imaginé ahorita
arriesgando la horita a caminar de noche
perdimos todo con los huracanes que
hubieron y nos quedamos en la calle el
presidente no nos apoya
nos vamos con dolor en nuestra alma
porque dejamos nuestra familia en aquí
en honduras
pero yo sé qué
y llegamos
al lugar de destino que llevamos vamos a
poder salir adelante en el nombre de
los obstáculos se presentaron en el
camino las autoridades hondureñas
incentivaron a los migrantes a regresar
ofreciendo transporte de vuelta mientras
que guatemala obligó a los viajeros a
presentar una prueba negativa de kobe 19
el paso del huracán eta y dos semanas
después el huracán gota golpeó duramente
noviembre la infraestructura y los
cultivos en honduras un centenar de
personas perdió la vida
y todos sueñan con llegar a eeuu donde
se preparan para la nueva administración
bajo la presidencia de joe biden el
presidente electo se ha comprometido a
seguir una política migratoria más
humana y ofrecer ayuda a centroamérica
para aliviar las presiones migratorias